so we can do a couple of things with
this this notation is very powerful okay
you can use it to generalize things for
instance if we go back to Pascal's
triangle we go back to this guy
I wanted to redraw him what would he
look like if we used this notation well
I'm gonna be drawing and I think you
should too
you don't need to redraw a lot oh wait
no I want to leave that one there I'll
do it over here
have you guys written what's in red
thank you that very first number up the
tongue in your diagram anyone we labeled
that as the zero with Road okay
so that would correspond to 1 plus X to
the power of 0 do you remember that okay
so it's the zero power and the zero of
coefficient which was one the next one
is that first throw right so this one
corresponds to one C 0 and then what C 1
and then I do the second Road and then I
do the third row you can see what's
going on here I do one more and then I
think that'll be enough to cause
okay now from this I want you to go back
to the list of properties that we
pointed out before when we were just
looking at this and having a look at
some of the numbers okay we can rephrase
all of those well most of those
properties in terms of this language in
a more sort of elegant concise way okay
I'll give you some examples have a look
at the out sides of the triangle we
didn't actually named this because it
seems so obvious right but now using
this petition it's less obvious having
look at the outsides all of them
although the numbers on the outsides are
all one right but now have a look at
what this new notation tells you write
all these terms out here and choose zero
on this side right and n choose n on
this side right so now he's a property
this is um properties again but you see
notation I can say that and choose 0 or
n choose 0 that's all of these guys on
the left okay they're all labeled soon
and choose n which is all these guys on
the right which is equal to 1 it's a
property and I can say it algebraically
in an actual equation ok and we also set
this symmetry to this right symmetry
this number matches this number this
number matches this number how would you
say it in NCR notation how would you
describe the symmetry ok if I picked out
some turn the earth and term okay
suppose this was the R term this would
be R equals 0 1 2 okay which time does
it match up to in here this is the um
this is a 7th row right so I'm thinking
this is 7 shoes - it matches up to this
guy this would be 7 C 3 C 4 C 5 7 5
right these to match that okay
let's try another one how about say down
to here okay this would be row nine nine
and this would be term zero one two
three or I could say if I had 1 plus 6
to the power of 9 it would be the third
coefficient along right makes you see
which number doesn't match up to and the
answer is this guy over here 3 4 5 6 now
these are all concrete numbers can we
generalize pretty abstract what NCR
going to be equal to which term doesn't
always match up to it's in the same Road
right so it's still good at the end
what's the number down the bottom two
and five they add up to yeah
three and six they out of ten it's it's
n - isn't it okay
that's the symmetry property but in
notation okay that makes sense there's
other things what other properties we
have we had on all of the terms added up
right there are always a power of two
how can we write that how could I write
that well if I want to name all of the
terms and choose zeros the first one the
next one will be n choose 1 and C 1 and
C 2 and so on what will be the last one
it's en and they all that up to 2 to the
power of M because I'm in the effort
look to power 6 to the sorry 2 to power
6 5 to power 6 2007 okay it's to the end
this is another reason why it's good to
start off with this being the 0th row
you see why people are just trying to
make Matz hard for you like why start
with zero right because here it makes
sense mathematically this is the zero
power of 2 in the first power of three
and then you get the idea
that's three there was another property
what was the property we started with it
was the addition property okay this is a
bit trickier you need to think hard for
this one
let me give us some more room how are
you going to explain how you're going to
articulate the addition property in
terms of all of this stuff this stuff
well the initial property means in order
to get to a term like this the web for
the place we got from would meet with
Easter Tomatoes right so this term here
is - yeah I'm gonna call him and choose
top right I've trained in I'm a tree on
now where did I get him from I went to
the previous row and I took those two
right
I should stop pointing and I'll just put
colors on so from work and I've got to
climb up one to run n minus one don't
know that's where I have to go to go
back up right so that's equal to n minus
1 plus n minus 1 these are two terms
from the previous row which tutors if
this is all right then it's gonna be R
minus 1 and R does that make sense
this is the addition property now it's
worth noting this is not the only way to
write the addition property I can write
it in a couple of different ways and
it's still the same property I'll give
you an example suppose I didn't want to
go up I didn't want to think about I
think that down how do I do the next row
okay well let's start with the case
we'll start with Sandy's - how do I go
from these two to this one okay if we
call this our starting point right call
that guy sorry this is born the same
property okay call that guy in CR okay
what's the guy next to it
in C one plus one that's the difference
same row different number pushed over
one okay which number do I get when I
add these two together well I go down a
row so this has become M plus one and
then which term alone do I get and the
answer is I get I get this term don't I
that's the R plus 1 term along okay now
can you see these two look quite
different like the numbers are all
mismatched but they're the same company
looked at from two different angles I
could do it from a couple more different
angles depending on which number I start
with okay but you get the idea and you
see where it comes from
okay let's see a couple of things to
finish now going to this add in this our
business I'm gonna write out one plus x
to the end okay
what's it gonna be equal to start with
the zero of 10 then the first term then
the second term what are the last to be
it's gonna be this guy in cheatin and
what will the power of X be it'll be n
when it okay now that's a bit long and
awkward and I have to have a doctored up
because I have no idea how many terms
there are okay but we have we've learnt
language to describe this already when
you're adding up a whole bunch of things
and you have to increment along to get
all of them and you know how many there
are in total how many terms on it in
time you started at zero so there are M
plus 1 terms when you want to add up a
whole bunch of things that are separate
we use Sigma notation don't we that's
how we do it it's a far more concise way
to say it how do i define it
I need a starting point and an end point
you could say I need a lower enough
bound right what's my lower bound where
do I begin
I started zero
and then I end a 10-0 to end gives me
the n plus 1 terms right ok so that's
how many I've got what does each term
look like what I put in here it'll be n
see ah like that which power of X and I
get again think carefully be carefully
what this represents is the eighth term
I go from R equals 0 to 1 to 2 3 or 4
and so on up until n so which power will
I get I'll get the odd power because it
has to change because 0 1 2 3 etc right
it's not next to the end because there's
only one next to the end there can be
only one you get the idea okay so there
you go that's that's the general term
amoun okay okay this big notation idea
it takes a little bit of time to wrap
your head around and especially like
when you look at this balloon or not
some people get their their introduction
to their first words and the teachers
mouth but under the heading binomial
theorem is this list of properties and
you're like I hope you can see it
basically comes from here that's where
it comes from
okay so if you can see this when you
look at this then you'll nail and you
won't mix up your ends and your arms and
your n minus ones and so on okay